this is what the end of the so-called
caliphate looks like broken Isis
families and militants giving themselves
up the thin shapes their clothes ragged
carry what they can
the young appear shell-shocked this girl
just stops
she is completely dazed
for weeks they've existed under heavy
bombardment in trenches and tunnels
some of the children emerge alone their
parents presumed to be dead
and as this mass of people clamber up to
safety it is the very young you notice
most the boy being carried appears
listless a primitive chest drain to
relieve internal bleeding swings below
him the fanatics that have survived have
had weeks to surrender they instead
chose to sacrifice their children to the
brutality of war most of the men are
wounded they're almost certainly
fighters their limbs badly bandaged we
ask this group how many are left inside
lots comes back the answer
but even in the organization's death
throes it is resisting the inevitable
[Applause]
Isis has just a tiny piece of land in
this nowhere place and they are
encircled yet some are still refusing to
give up you can see a thick curtain of
black smoke behind me
they've been pounded now for hours of
course it nobody knows how many Islamic
state fighters are still inside and
putting up resistance but it can't they
can't surely hold out against all of
this for that much longer and the
violent spasms of a dying cult still
holds danger with bullets zipping
overhead we had to move to cover
but SDF fighters no they have won this
battle these men on the way back from
the front told us - is finished and that
is certainly what it looks like for an
organization that used to project terror
through video propaganda its militants
now look weak and some cannot even stand
Alex Rossi Sky News bagus
[Music]